Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
here's something to celebrate.
Today is the last day
of dry January.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What an accomplishment.
I can't believe
we all went an entire month
lying to each other.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news here.
Today, President Biden
was here in New York City
to talk about the funding
for his infrastructure law.
Yeah, Biden's speech was great
because for 20 minutes,
the city that never sleeps
got a quick little snooze.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, this week,
Biden's been touring the country
to talk about
his infrastructure plan.
Meanwhile, people are talking
about all these videos
that Donald Trump Jr.
keeps releasing
where he can't stop
using air quotes.
[ Laughter ]
You see this?
So, we decided
to combine the two.
So, here's Joe Biden's head
on Don Jr.'s body.
Enjoy.
-But, folks, look,
I made a thousand trips
through this tunnel,
so I've been through this tunnel
a thousand times.
And, you know,
when folks talk about
how badly the Baltimore Tunnel
needs an upgrade,
you don't need me to tell you.
I've been there.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I -- I also, I feel like --
is it me?
I feel like Biden's voice is
kind of sounding like
a Jennifer Coolidge impression.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "You don't need me
to tell you.
Oh, my God."
[ Laughter ]
"I feel the Republicans
are trying to murder me."
[ Laughter ]
"I can go
for a hot tub real bad."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Here's some big news.
On May 11th, President Biden
is going to end the COVID
public-health emergency.
I'm pretty sure the public
ended the health emergency
a while ago.
[ Laughter ]
Today, I saw a guy
open a Starbucks bathroom
with his tongue.
I go, "I think it's over."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey!
Hey!
-Listen to this.
According to researchers,
American democracy
could be failing 'cause elected
officials are getting too old.
Well, a few politicians
in Washington
were quick to respond about them
being too old.
First up,
President Biden said...
[ Laughter ]
And Bernie Sanders said...
And finally,
this Senator said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
No cap.
I saw that former president
Trump is suing Bob Woodward
for releasing interview
recordings that Trump says
that he never agreed could be
shared with the public.
And if you listen,
you can actually tell why
Trump didn't want these
released.
Check these out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, that's two words.
[ Applause ]
One word.
Did you guys see this?
Amid all the controversy,
Congressman George Santos said
that he is temporarily
stepping down from his House
committee assignments.
-Yeah!
[ Scattered applause ]
In a statement, Santos said...
Then he said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, he said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I didn't know that.
Well, some movie news.
Today, Warner Bros. announced
that "The Batman II,"
starring Robert Pattinson,
will be released
in October of 2025.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not to be outdone,
Marvel just announced
that there's eight new movies
coming out tomorrow,
and you have to see them all.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, the weather
has been crazy this winter.
Some places have a ton of snow,
others haven't gotten any.
But one thing's for sure,
when you're watching
a weather report,
you just want to skip
the boring parts and get right
to the important stuff.
Well, it turns out you can.
For instance,
if you're watching a report,
you can skip this part.
-Good morning.
Well, obviously,
we're getting a nice break
from the rain.
-Yeah, and you go
right to this part.
-This is essentially now
a part of the Passaic River
in this neighborhood.
-Wait a second.
[ Laughter ]
-"Wait.
What are you guys doing?"
-"What the...?"
Maybe it was two Jesuses.
-Here's another example.
You can skip this part.
-Hey, Michael, I hear you're
slipping and sliding out there
on the Weather Deck.
-Took a look at this
wide view here
of the Weather Deck.
-Yeah, and you can go
right to this part.
-It's just completely
glazed over.
And...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
That did not feel good.
-Ooh, ooh.
-Ow.
-That's right.
You can --
You can skip this part.
-58 right now
in the Twin Cities.
It's a comfortable
Tuesday night.
46 in Hinckley.
57 in Marshall.
-And go right to this.
-In Winona --
Ooh, that's funky.
[ Laughter ]
You guys want
one Jennifer or two Jennifers?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, here's a final example.
You can skip this part.
-All right.
So, I got my trusty stopwatch.
And here they come
down the hill.
-And go right to this.
-Ruben is in the lead.
And here comes Alan --
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was a bad idea.
-Oh!
-So much better!
Wow!
-That's a 360.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Whew!
Guys, get this --
I read that Whole Foods
is asking suppliers
to lower their prices.
Yeah.
We've gotten to the point
where even Whole Foods can't
afford Whole Foods.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard about a 22-year-old
basketball coach
who was fired
after she allegedly posed
as a 13-year-old girl and played
in a J.V. basketball game.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the coach was fired,
but on the bright side,
she was just selected
to replace George Santos
on two House committees.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that amazing?
[ Applause ]
That's not all bad.
Finally, everyone,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go, everyone.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
[ Crowd cheers ]
Good.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Hopefully you vote for
all of them.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Every vote counts.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we're going to tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
[ Laughter ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright,
you guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
First tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow!
♪♪
-That's the joke.
That's the -- No one
has phoned it in harder.
"I got a good name for
those things -- blueberries."
Wow.
-This might get negative.
-You voted --
It's gonna be negative votes?
-Yeah,
I think it'll be negative.
-I think -- Wow.
I mean,
it was a stunned silence.
-Yeah, it was a stunned silence.
-Alright, you say 50% --
less than 50%.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Wow. I kind of agree with you.
Tariq, what do you think?
-I'm going to agree
with Higgins on this one.
-You didn't vote?
You always vote yes.
-Yes, I vote yes.
-But on this one, did you?
-I kind of did, yeah.
-Alright.
He's very honest. Votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
-Ooh, my God!
-Oh, yeah!
-Thirty-three.
-Was it that bad?
That's not an original name --
blueberries.
This guy kind of phoned it in
a little bit.
-More like a sentence.
-This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
There's got to be a --
-This is going to be better.
-He's got a Bat phone.
He's got everything.
-You can't call him?
-No, he has to keep
looking out his window and go,
"Oh, not yet."
-Anybody? No.
-"They need me?
No, they don't need me yet."
Alright,
let's see the results here.
I feel better about this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh!
-Oh, wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, thank you.
-Yeah.
-Now I know that
your thumbs-up button works,
that's good to know.
I was worried for a second.
Alright, this next one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Alright, let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah, not bad.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Batman.
Batman's still in the lead.
-Yeah.
-Alright, how about this?
Next up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
We tried it.
We tried as hard as we could.
Not going to work.
Not going to be a thing.
-People tried.
-People tried hard.
They tried with kale.
Kale kind of
took off for a little bit.
-Brussels sprouts took off.
-Had one or two good records.
-Yeah.
-Cauliflower, it ain't --
just not going to do it.
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, wow!
-Oh, wow!
No, thank you.
-Some people chose
not to play at all.
"I am not --
I'm not going to waste my b--
my energy to type
in that button there."
-Wow.
-Alright,
this last one here is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I feel like it's going to be --
-I like this one.
-It's the Batman.
-Yeah, Batman for the win.
-It's gotta be. Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results
right here.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh, not bad.
-Oh!
The winner is Batman!
Oh, my God.
-Whoa!
-"...a light in the sky."
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.